PROFESSOR: Today we begin the
third major part of the class.
We've done paper
folding, linkage folding,
and now we're going to
do polyhedron folding.
The very last topic we
did was hinged dissection,
which is somewhere in the
middle of all these things.
But with polyhedron
folding, we're
thinking about a two
dimensional surface
in 3D, something like
a cube, and we're
interested in cutting along
the edges of that shape
or somehow cutting along
the surface-- that's
a good cutting-- and then
unfolding into some flat shape.
So this is a standard cross
unfolding of the cube.
This is the unfolding process,
and of course the reverse
is the folding process, and
both of them are interesting.
We're going to start
thinking about unfolding.
That's one of the most
practical problems here.
You really want to build some
3D shape out of sheet material.
What shape do you
cut out in order
to bend it into that surface?
So you start with the surface.
You need to figure out where
to cut so that when you unfold,
you get something
that has no overlap.
If you want to make
it from one sheet,
it shouldn't have any overlap,
and ideally just one piece
because then you have to do
less welding or edge joining
to make that surface.
So today and the
next couple lectures
will be all about unfolding,
and then eventually we
will turn to the reverse
problem, folding problem.
And there are two
kinds of unfolding.
The one that I just
drew is an edge
unfolding because it
only cuts along edges.
Edge unfolding only cut
along edges of the surface.
This property is nice.
If you're building
something, you
don't want to have
visible seems.
You have to be
bent at the edges,
so it's not such a big
deal if you're also
fusing along an edge.
But in general, you could
imagine cutting anywhere
on the surface, and
this is an example
where the solid red
lines are cutting
on what you see and the
dotted red lines were
cutting on the backside.
And when you unfold that thing,
you get this stoplight polygon,
and this is what we call a
general unfolding, or just
unfolding.
There you can cut anywhere.
In both cases, we want
one piece, no overlap,
but you can change where
you're allowed to cut.
So those are the
rules of the game,
or two possible
rules of the game.
And let me tell you what's
known about these kinds
of unfoldings.
I've mentioned it way
back in lecture one.
so we can think
about edge unfolding,
we can think about
general unfolding,
and we can think about
them for convex polyhedra--
simple things like the
cube have no dents--
or general polyhedra,
non-convex polyhedra.
And status is these
two corners are open.
This one is solved.
It can always be done.
You can always generally
unfold a convex polyhedron,
but we don't know about
general polyhedra.
Edge unfolding of
convex polyhedra,
we don't know whether
it's possible,
but for non-convex
polyhedra, we know
that's too much to hope for.
Not always possible.
Both of these questions
could go either way,
but we know in various
generalizations, easy case
of convex polyhedra general
unfolding, we can do it.
The most restrictive,
hardest situation
is edge unfolding
non-convex polyhedra.
That's too much.
But each of these
things, we don't know.
And these are some of the
biggest open questions
remaining in geometric folding
algorithms, this field.
I'm going to talk mostly
about these three things
today, so this open problem
and these two results.
And then this topic will
essentially be next lecture.
Obviously it's not solved, but
we still have a lot to say.
There are various
partial results
toward solving both
of those problems,
I would say more on this one.
This one is five centuries old.
This one is one
decade old or so.
So I need to set the stage
a little bit before I
can talk about any
of these things,
so let me start with a
little bit of terminology.
We've in some sense talked
about curvature before.
I don't think I gave
it this name, though,
in the context of origami.
And I use it almost
subconsciously
so it's good for
me to define it.
If you have some vertex
on your polyhedron.
Let's say we're looking
at a corner of a cube,
so this has three 90 degree
angles coming together.
You sum those
angles, we get 270,
and then you take
360 minus that sum,
and that is your curvature.
This is going to be 90.
And what I really care about
is whether the curvature
is positive, 0, or negative.
Positive curvature, which
is what we got here--
this is plus 90-- is
like a convex cone.
So if you're thinking about
convex polyhedra, which
is one of the situations
we care about,
you'll always get positive or
0, maybe, curvature vertices,
depending on what
you're thinking about.
Zero, this is like
a piece of paper,
so this is what you might call
flat, but it's locally flat.
It could be drawn
flat or we know
how to fold pieces of paper.
You never change the curvature.
The sum of the
instant face angles
will always stay the same, no
matter how you fold this thing.
Curvature is an invariant.
If you just think locally and
forget about the actual folding
of the thing, it's kind of flat.
So you can think of this
as a piece of paper.
We talked about
these two situations
in the context of Kawasaki's
theorem way back when.
Kawasaki's theorem
applied for both
of these for the negative
curvature case, which
is when you have lots
of material all joined
at a single point,
something like this.
Then Kawasaki's theorem
changed a little bit.
There were some other
cases that could happen.
So when you have
tons of material,
this can only happen in
a non-convex polyhedron.
That's sort of the point.
If you're a convex
polyhedron, you
know you have to have
only these two situations.
Where do you get flat vertices?
Well, if you think of
this point as a vertex
and you add up all the angles
around it, well, that's 360.
360 minus 360 is 0.
So you have zero curvature on
all the faces and on the edges.
Also, if you look here,
you have 180 and other 180.
That adds to 360.
And then at the actual
vertices, that's
where you have positive
curvature for a convex
polyhedron.
So just some terminology.
Get used to the idea of positive
curvature, zero curvature,
and negative curvature.
Then we have the
idea of a cutting.
So cutting is just,
what edges do you cut?
It's the red stuff
in this picture.
What edges do you cut
in order to unfold?
So this is an unfolding, the
mapping here, but the red part,
I'll call it cutting.
Sometimes it's also
called an unfolding,
but that can be a
little confusing.
The main point here is I want
to talk about what constraints
cutting must satisfy in order
to be valid so we can just
get a sense of what
is happening here.
If you look at these pictures,
you can see two properties.
One is that the cuttings
visit all the vertices
of the polyhedron.
So there's this red stuff.
The red stuff is connected.
It's acyclic, so it's actually
a tree in these pictures,
and it's visiting
all the corners.
Even back here, it's
visited on the back.
Is that always true?
Most of those properties
are mostly true,
but it depends a little bit.
One thing that is
sure is the cutting
must span all non-zero
curvature vertices.
But I do have to say
"non-zero curvature." "Spans"
just means visits.
You have to hit all the
vertices of non-zero curvature
because anything of
non-zero curvature
can't be flattened by itself.
It needs to be cut.
At that point, the cutting has
to have degree at least one.
With zero curvature
vertices, even if they're not
flat in three dimensions,
you could flatten them
because we know locally,
it really is a flat thing.
So there may not be any cuts
at zero curvature vertices.
Most of the time, we won't
have to worry about them,
but something to think about.
Everybody else you have to span.
You can say even more.
If you have very
negative curvature,
if the curvature of a vertex
is less than some integer,
k times 360 with a minus
sign in front, then cutting
must have degree strictly
more than k plus 1.
So if you have
negative curvature,
you know you have to
have at least two cuts
for a negative curvature
vertex because if you
had negative curvature--
one of these things--
you made a single cut.
Then all that material
is still there.
If you then flattened it,
it's going to overlap itself
because you're trying
to flatten it into 360.
There's more than
360 material there.
So negative curvature already,
you need two vertices.
That's the plus 1 here.
And as soon as you get to
smaller than negative 360,
then you have to have at least
three cuts and so on, just
to partition up into
at most 360 groups.
This is useful.
Negative curvature is basically
really tough to unfold
and we'll use that to make
counter examples here.
What else?
your polyhedron has no handles,
then cutting has no cycles.
A handle is something
of higher genus.
If this is your polyhedron,
we call this a handle.
You have sort of
a blob down here
and you have a connection
from one place to the other.
If you have a
handle, you can have
a cycle of cuts like this
that does not disconnect
the surface, but we
basically never think
about that situation.
Whenever we're thinking of
something of genus zero,
like a convex polyhedron or a
regular, non-convex polyhedron,
you really shouldn't have
a cycle in your cutting
because if you
had a cycle, you'd
disconnect your
surface into two parts
normally, if you're like
a sphere or like a disk.
That's the acyclic
condition and when it holds.
Some other good things.
If a polyhedron has no
boundary and no handles,
and the unfolding has
no holes, then cutting
is a spanning tree.
Spanning tree, it's a concept
we've used a few times.
It's just a tree.
In this case, it's got
to visit all the vertices
of non-zero curvature and
it's a tree, so it's connected
and it's acyclic.
The main new thing here
is that it's connected.
We've already said
that it should
be acyclic with no
handles, we've already
said that it should
span everybody,
so it's sort of a
summary theorem,
but we have a whole
bunch of conditions here.
In particular, this will hold
if your polyhedron is convex.
So for convex polyhedra,
you have a spanning tree,
and that's what's going
on in this picture even
for general unfoldings.
That's the interesting case.
Here, it's maybe more
obvious, here it's
a little less obvious.
And to sort of see what could go
wrong here, I have an example.
This is a non-convex polyhedron.
There's a whole
bunch of views of it
up here, and in
particular this top view.
What we're doing is slicing
along just those two
edges and some other
stuff around the outside,
but in particular, we
cut those two edges
and there aren't any
other cuts around there.
A polyhedron is set up so
that when you open it up,
this works out.
It's nice and flat.
This is extremely rare.
If you perturbed this
example, it wouldn't hold.
But you can set things up
so that, in fact, what's
happening is that the total
curvature-- this vertex has
positive curvature, this has
negative, this has positive,
and the sum of those
three curvatures is zero,
and that's what
allows this to be flat
because the total curvature
in that little region is zero,
and that's when things
are allowed to be flat.
So you can cut here and make
a separate collection of cuts
on the outside, but
it's disconnected,
so this is kind of weird.
Most of the time, things
will be connected,
and as long as your
unfolding has no holes--
and for an unfolding
to have holes,
you'd have to have
this weird property
that a bunch of curvatures sum
to zero like in that picture--
as long as you don't
have that, you're OK.
Let's get to these theorems.
Actually, one thing
related to this problem,
general unfolding of
arbitrary polyhedra,
is you can't be too
general what you
mean by non-convex polyhedra.
So we have this example.
It's the simplest nasty
polyhedron there is this.
It has one vertex at the
top there with a big dot
that has negative curvature.
There's more than 360
degrees of material
from all these triangles.
And that's sort of
all that it has.
This is the polyhedron.
This is what we call
boundary of the polyhedron.
So far, all the polyhedra
I've done haven't had that,
and you may have
seen that I assumed
that it wasn't there
for that last lemma.
This polyhedron can't
be unfolded at all
in one piece, no overlap.
Why?
Because it has one vertex.
You could think of
these as vertices,
but they're kind of flat.
Everything's flat
except that one point.
It has negative curvature.
Negative curvature,
we said you have
to have at least two
cuts coming in there.
If you just made one cut, then
when you flatten this thing,
it'll overlap itself locally.
So there's got to be at least
two cuts coming in there.
I don't think that
even matters much.
I mean, there's at
least one, certainly.
Where could those
guys go, those cuts?
They have to wander
around the surface.
If they just stop in
the middle of nowhere,
then you're sort of doing
nothing because a cut that just
stops in the middle
of a flat vertex,
well, you might as well
not have done that cut,
so you could erase it.
So it's got to go somewhere.
They could go to each other, in
which case you've made a cycle
and then you've disconnected
your surface because this
is like a disk, or they
could go to the boundary.
And if they both
go to the boundary,
again, you disconnect
your surface, two pieces.
So this is kind of pathetic,
but you can't unfold this
with one piece, no overlap.
So when I say, in
this picture, and I
say that it's open whether
non-convex polyhedra can
be generally unfolded, I
mean non-convex polyhedra
without boundary.
I'll even give you
handles if you want.
I'm not sure that
it matters too much,
but boundary seems to
make a big difference.
So what's wrong
is this polyhedron
is kind of incomplete,
and as long
as you close it up somehow
and don't have these boundary
effects, then maybe you can
generally unfold everything.
That's this question.
That was a little bit on this.
We'll come back to
it more next lecture.
Next, I want to do this one,
general unfolding of convex
polyhedra.
This is really the most
positive news I could give you.
All this unfolding stuff,
it's the one good result.
We know several good results,
but in terms of that table,
it's our only good result.
And to do that, there's a bunch
of solutions to this problem.
They all use the idea
of shortest paths.
The shortest path is a
path that's shortest.
So you have some surface,
you have some points.
You do this all the
time when you're
flying between two cities.
You follow a shortest
path on a sphere.
It's not straight
in three dimensions.
It's the shortest thing subject
to lying on that surface, what
is the shortest path you can do?
So you're used to
it on a sphere.
It's a little weirder
on a polyhedron,
but it's just the same idea.
Take all the possible paths you
could, find the shortest one.
You fix the two
endpoints, x and y,
and you get to optimize this.
Whatever is shortest
is the right thing.
I have some pictures of
what they look like here.
So these are some
convex polyhedra.
They're probably random
points on a sphere,
take the convex hull.
And then we pick some vertex,
or some point x in the corner
there, and this is
computing the shortest paths
from x to every other
vertex on the polyhedron.
So they look very
straight in this case
because the polyhedron
is almost a sphere.
They look kind of like great
circular arcs on a sphere,
but they're not quite.
You can look carefully
at an edge here,
this does bend a little bit.
It's a bit subtle.
It bends only a little bit
because the property you want
is if you look at this
triangle and this triangle
and you unfold
them-- so right now,
they have some dihedral
angle between them,
and if you open it out
so that they're flat,
then this line
should be straight.
Still the case that shortest
paths are straight lines,
but only when you unfold.
That's the idea.
So if you look at all
the triangles are visited
by a path, and you unfold them
to be a straight thing-- this
is called developing, you
flatten it out-- then actually,
the shortest path will
be a straight line,
so that makes it really
easy to draw these things.
There still might be multiple
candidates, like to get here,
should I go this way or
the other way around,
but each of those will
be locally straight,
and this is a property
called geodesic.
Shortest paths always
unfold straight.
And in general, anything
that unfolds straight,
it might not even be
shortest, is a geodesic.
These are like locally shortest.
Locally, you can't
make them any shorter,
but they might have
made the wrong choice.
They might have gone
around the wrong way.
Geodesic means going
straight for a long time.
You could actually
spiral around and do
all sorts of crazy things.
But shortest paths
never cross themselves
because if you had the shortest
path that crossed itself,
that wasn't shortest.
You should have just
gotten rid of this part
and gone straight
through the crossing.
That's sort of trivial.
And there's another
good, fun property
that you may not have
noticed in those figures,
but they never pass through
positive curvature vertex.
So if you look at
these pictures,
they might end at a
positive curvature vertex
because that's where we told
the shortest path to go,
but in the middle, they're
always crossing edges.
This is a convex polyhedron so
everything's positive curvature
or zero.
In that case, the
paths can really only
go through zero
curvature points.
They might start
and end wherever,
but in between, they
never hit a corner.
Why?
Because if you have a
positive curvature vertex--
I'm just going to sketch this
idea-- if you went up here
in order to go back down
somewhere like there,
it's always better to
shortcut a little bit
and not go through the vertex.
It's better to go around
one way or the other.
I'm just going to wave my
hands at that, but it's true.
So what?
Shortest paths are going to
be a really powerful tool
for finding unfoldings.
In particular, I want to
define the star, that picture,
of all shortest
paths from one point.
And do I want points here?
I think I want vertices.
That's the picture that we drew.
The interesting thing about all
the shortest paths, they all
start from the same point,
they never hit each other.
So not only does a
shortest path not hit
itself, but if you take many
shortest paths, or even two
shortest paths from a
common starting point,
they can't hit each other.
It could be one is
a subset of another.
For example, if I took
the shortest path to here
and then I also took the
shortest path to a point
just beyond it,
well, one's going
to be a prefix of the other.
Other than that, they will
never cross each other.
I'm going to just assert
that, not prove it here.
So really, it does
look like a star.
In fact, you could fill
in more shortest paths.
You could take the shortest
path to here, for example,
and it'll fit in nicely, kind
of bisect that angle in there.
It's a very simple
kind of structure.
It's just from a point, you
have all this stuff going out.
They never hit each
other except at something
called the cut locus, also
called the ridge tree.
And these are points with
non-unique shortest paths to x.
So we're fixing some point, x.
So here's a simpler polyhedron.
It's just a
square-based pyramid.
We're picking x to be in
the middle of this face,
and drawn in these black
lines are the shortest paths
from x to all the vertices.
Here, that's a straight line.
This one, if you unfolded
it, it would be straight,
and there's some similar
ones on the back.
And I think this is the back
in case you want to see.
There's one back face that you
can't see at all, C, behind B
here, and that's
what it looks like.
There's no shortest paths there.
Now, there's these dashed lines.
That's the ridge tree.
That's the cut locus.
And these are points on the
backside with respect to x.
If you're going from x,
you go around behind to C,
or you could go from x around
behind to D and then to C.
At some point, those things meet
and are still of equal length.
So here, if you're
trying to go to x,
you could go around this way or
you could go around this way.
They will be the same
length, and all the points
with that property
are the dashed lines.
Now, if you're familiar
with [? Vornar ?] diagrams,
this is the [? Vornar ?]
diagram of one point, x.
Imagine you plant grass over
your polyhedron, you light
a fire here, it burns at
uniform speed in all directions.
Where the fire meets
itself on the backside,
that is the ridge tree.
That is the
[? Vornar ?] diagram.
So it's kind of intuitive
that it's there.
Maybe less obvious
is that it's a tree
and it's a spanning tree.
It hits all the vertices.
So it's a natural cutting.
That's why it's
called the cut locus,
and it works really well.
And it's called the
source unfolding.
Source unfolding goes
back to the mid '80s.
A bunch of people
discovered it for
various computational
geometry applications.
They didn't care about
unfolding at the time.
And it's kind of obvious after
you think about it for a while,
trying to solve this
general unfolding problem.
Once you have this structure,
cut along the cut locus,
unfold the star of
shortest paths from x.
So let's do it for this example.
It's the same
example on the left.
This is the star unfolding.
I've just splayed out
everything, so at the boundary,
I'm cutting at the dashed part.
That's the cut locus.
Ignore these little
dashed lines.
Those are just edges, unfolded.
And what's happening is that
all the shortest paths are all
here.
If I look at any shortest path
from x on the left diagram,
I can map it to a line
segment starting from x.
x was a flat vertex.
It has 360 degrees of
material around it.
I just chose it to be somewhere
in the middle somewhere.
Doesn't matter other than that.
And now there's 360 degrees of
material on the flat unfolding.
That's great.
And you pick any
direction here, you
can map it to a corresponding
direction over there
on the surface, see where
that shortest path would
go if you kept going until
you were no longer shortest.
When you stop being shortest,
the edge of that place
is the ridge tree, and
that's where you cut.
You stop your segment there.
So it's actually pretty obvious
this thing doesn't overlap
because all of
these shortest paths
are going in different
directions from x.
What you have is what we call
a star shaped polygon around x.
Every point on the
surface is visible from x
because we just sort of
unrolled it to be right there.
That's the source unfolding.
It's a little hard to
see the 3D diagrams,
but it's actually really easy
once you draw those shortest
paths.
So the source unfolding
is star shaped.
We have another unfolding
called the star unfolding,
which is not star shaped.
Very confusing.
I mean, what you call one
doesn't matter too much.
This unfolding was
mentioned in 1948
by Alexandrov, who
we'll be hearing
about more in the
future, but wasn't
improved to
non-overlap until '92.
So this one is much less
obvious that it doesn't overlap,
and I'm not going
to prove it here.
But it goes back to
this idea of star.
Say, OK, this cut locus
is nice, but let's
focus on the star
of shortest paths
from one point to all
the other vertices.
Instead of keeping those paths
as the things that you unroll,
what if we cut along them?
It's another natural thing to
try and it turns out to work.
So here, we cut along the star.
We've already
proved this result,
every convex polyhedron
is generally unfoldable.
Just with that picture,
it's very easy.
But hey, it's fun to have more.
And this is what the
star unfolding looks
like for the same example.
This is a little less obvious,
but if you think about it,
the star, the set
of all shortest
paths to all the vertices,
is a spanning tree.
It hits all the vertices
because we told it to,
and it's a tree
because it's just
all these edges coming
together at a point.
So it's a natural cutting also.
And magically it works.
How it works is a
little less obvious.
You see here the ridge tree
drawn on the unfolding,
and you can see all the
parts and map the letter E,
this is the bottom square,
and stays connected.
It's just like you
reattach everything
around the ridge tree
and it doesn't overlap.
It's quite difficult, I think,
to give intuition why this
doesn't overlap, but it doesn't.
I'll wave my hands
at some point when
we have the necessary
tools to prove it,
I can mention how it's done.
But we don't have them yet.
We'll get them in a couple
of lectures, I think.
These results can be extended
also in various directions.
Let me tell you briefly
about some extensions.
For a long time, these
were the two ways
to solve that problem
and that was sort of it.
It would be nice, for example,
to have some general family
of unfoldings that includes the
star unfolding and the source
unfolding and there's
something in the middle,
but we don't necessarily
know what that is.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How do you find
the creases is your question?
You find the creases because
you know for every point
here where it was
on the surface,
and if it was on an edge,
then it's a crease point.
That's the easy way to do it.
I don't know if that's
a satisfactory answer,
but it can be done.
AUDIENCE: Does it matter
where you choose x to be?
PROFESSOR: Does it matter
It will change the unfolding.
It will never overlap,
but in that sense
there's a whole family
of star unfoldings,
depending on where you move x.
There's a whole family
of source unfoldings
depending on where you move x.
AUDIENCE: Does it make it
more efficient, any choice?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
some of the unfoldings
might have more cuts,
some might have less cuts.
You're going to
get more cuts when
you have-- depends
how you count.
In some sense, there's only
n cuts, n shortest paths.
But a shortest path
might cut over many faces
or it might just
cut over one face.
Depends where x is.
If you choose x to
be in a nice place,
maybe you could get
away with fewer cuts
and have to do less welding, but
there's no theory about that.
More questions.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
matter where you put x.
If it works at one spot, it
basically works at every spot.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For
convex polyhedra, it
works no matter where you put x.
For non-convex polyhedra, some
x's might work, some might not.
Here, let me show you.
Here's more star unfoldings.
Cool.
They're really crazy looking
and not really star shaped.
There isn't one point
that can see everything.
They look kind of spiky like a
star, but it's quite different.
These are random
points on a sphere,
like take 42 random points on
a sphere, take the convex hull,
then take a star unfolding.
Here's an example with
a non-convex polyhedron.
So one thing we hoped for
for a little while briefly
was that if you only had one
vertex of negative curvature,
which is this one, maybe if
you choose x to be right there
and did the star
unfolding, because that
cuts x into lots of
little tiny pieces, then
maybe it would unfold about
overlap, but it doesn't work.
We were destroyed.
In fact, you can
show neither of them
will work in general for
a non-convex polyhedra,
so there's no hope of
solving this problem
with these techniques, at least
with these exact algorithms.
You might get lucky,
but most of the time,
I think they won't work.
Currently, x is a point.
You can actually
let x be-- I guess
I'm not going to
be safe-- I'm going
to call it a geodesic path.
There's some restrictions
on when this is allowed,
but the idea is you
have your surface,
you take some straight
path on the surface,
and then you take
shortest paths from there.
And if you just think
about the source unfolding
where you keep x intact
and unfold from there,
the picture is
going to look like,
well, you have
this straight line
when you unfold that
thing, and then you
have this nice star
of stuff around it.
And under some
simple conditions,
that will work without overlap.
What's more impressive is
that the star unfolding
works from a source like that.
Again, there are
some restrictions
on x that I'm not
going to define here,
but it can be done.
These are two very recent
papers by O'Rourke and Itoh
and Vilku from the
last two years.
So that's exciting.
We now have four general methods
for unfolding convex polyhedra.
Again, these are big families.
You can choose
any geodesic path.
Maybe some are
nicer than others.
You can do higher dimensions.
Star unfolding doesn't
really make sense
in higher dimensions.
I don't think I've
thought about it much,
but source unfolding
makes sense.
So you have some four polytopes,
a little hard to imagine.
You take some point and
just radiate out from there,
unfold like that until you hit
yourself, and then you stop,
and that works in any dimension.
Source unfolding works
in any dimension.
That's fairly recent,
2003, Miller and Pak.
Another thing you can do
is continuous blooming.
This is an idea posed by
Connolly several years
back and then solved
last year, I guess.
It was presented in Japan.
This is about folded states
versus folding motions,
an issue we have thought
about many times in origami.
It was easy for any
polygonal piece of paper.
We could go from
unfolded to folded state
by a continuous motion
without self intersection.
For linkages, it
was the big deal.
It was all about, can
we get from a to b?
For convex polyhedra, you can
do it, continuous blooming.
This is in the middle of an
algorithm of continuously
blooming the source unfolding.
So here's our point x.
This is the cube, and
the source unfolding
of a cube for this
point x in the center
of a face, these four vertical
lines and then a little x
on the top side.
The algorithm unfolds
one edge at a time
but in a very specific order.
So it ends up unfolding this
entire house shape first,
and then it's done
one edge of this one,
and then it's going to fold
the other one down and then
unfold one, two for the
backside, and then one,
two for the left side.
And you can show that
will not self intersect
as long as you had
a convex polyhedron.
It's not obvious but it's true.
There are some other
results that if you
have any unfolding that doesn't
self intersect at the end,
you can add some cuts and make
it actually continuously bloom.
It's kind of like
hinged dissections.
It may not work by
itself, but you'd
cut the pieces into smaller
pieces and then it will work.
That's pretty good news,
and source unfolding just
works as is.
I might talk about that
some future lecture.
Not known, for example, whether
the star unfolding continuously
blooms.
That sounds a
little scary to me.
We don't actually have
an unfolding of a convex
polyhedron that does
not continuously bloom.
I think there should be one,
but that's an open problem.
Is this always possible, or
is there some crazy collection
of cuts that you cannot escape?
That's that, general
unfolding of convex polyhedra.
Let's turn to the--
it's not the last topic.
We still want to
cover both of these.
Next topic is edge unfolding
of convex polyhedra.
Now, this problem,
as I said, goes
back to 1525,
implicitly at least,
by this guy, Albrecht
Durer, who was a cool guy.
This is Renaissance time.
He did many different things.
I guess painter is maybe
his primary profession,
but he did a lot of
different things.
He studied early perspective,
all that good stuff.
This is one of
his famous prints.
It was actually on display
at the MFA last year,
I got to see it, and it
has a little polyhedron
thrown in there.
It's a nice polyhedron.
How did he draw them?
Well, he probably built
models out of some material.
And he was just
generally interested
in the third dimension
and understanding
how all these things worked, and
so he made a lot of unfoldings
in this book.
This is the original title.
Here's a translation.
Titles were a lot
longer in those days.
The Painter's Manual
is what I usually
call it, "A Manual of
Measurement of Lines, Areas,
and Solids by Means
of Compass and Ruler
Assembled by Albrecht Durer for
the Use of all Lovers of Art
with Appropriate
Illustrations Arranged
to be Printed in
the Year MDXXV."
And I don't even know what the
subtitle is, but there you go.
If you read German,
I'm told this
is a challenge because
of the old script.
So unfoldings like this.
He did mostly Archimedian
solids in this book.
This book is several
hundred pages long.
I have a copy.
This is a
cuboctahedron unfolded.
He is only cutting along edges,
and he liked this, I presume,
for building models.
Here's a fancy
one, the snub cube.
This one, I think,
might have an error.
A couple of them have very small
errors, but for the most part,
he was the inventor
of edge unfolding.
Now, he didn't ask, is this
always possible, but we did.
Mathematicians did in
1976, I believe, or '85.
'75, G. C. Shephard, geometer.
He was the first one
to write it in a paper,
does every convex polyhedron
have an edge unfolding?
So what can I tell you
about this problem?
It's hard.
Many people have
thought about it.
I'm not really sure
that it's possible.
A lot of people do, though.
It's possible for
a lot of polyhedra.
In fact, every polyhedron
we've tried to unfold we
have eventually unfolded--
convex polyhedron.
Simple set of examples are
the Archimedian solids.
Doesn't take that much effort to
find unfoldings of all of them.
You can do this with exhaustive
search or just playing around.
A lot of people have
done this over the years.
This is all the
unfoldings of those guys.
There's a lot of
heuristic software
for actually doing this.
I think the coolest one
right now is Pepakura.
If you want to build a
paper model of something,
you have a 3D model
thrown into Pepakura
and it'll probably give you
a one piece unfolding, even
for non-convex shapes.
Even though it's
not always possible,
it'll do edge
cuttings, it'll try
to do some exhaustive search,
and usually does pretty well.
Sometimes it'll use
multiple pieces.
That's the catch.
There's a link in
the lecture notes.
The most thorough
mathematical search
is by this guy, Wolfram
Schlickenrieder,
who wrote the equivalent
of a master's thesis
in Berlin 13 years ago.
I just wrote to him
about it yesterday.
I was like, hey,
this is cool stuff.
Can I show it in my lecture?
He was like, yeah, it lives on.
He had a class of 10
different algorithms,
around that many,
possible algorithms
for unfolding all
convex polyhedra,
and then he came up with
a dozen different families
of polyhedra.
I don't have the polyhedra
drawn here, just the unfoldings.
They're generators of
big classes of polyhedra.
He applied every
algorithm to every class.
Ideally, you get an algorithm
that works for all classes
or you find a class that
foils all algorithms.
Sadly, he found neither.
Every algorithm was
foiled by some example,
yet every example was
foiled by some algorithm.
It's really annoying, but here's
some examples where they fail.
They just barely fail, just a
couple triangles are messed up.
Little squares are messed up.
I think these are called
the turtle polyhedra.
It's like a big, flat thing
and then a dome on top.
So inconclusive, I
guess, is the answer.
There was one algorithm that
had a degree of freedom.
You had to choose
a direction, then
you cut along all the edges
that are most in that direction.
And there was a conjecture
on the table from this thesis
that maybe for every
polyhedron, there
is a direction that
works, but then
that was destroyed
four years ago.
Brendan Lucier from Waterloo
proved that that's not true.
He found a polyhedron
that doesn't
work from any direction.
So at the moment, we have
no candidate algorithms,
which makes me worry whether
this could possibly be true.
We have some more bad examples.
Here are some annoying things,
like a cube with a corner
cut off.
It's a very local thing, but
you can mess up really easily.
It's actually quite common
to mess up, I would say,
even though for things
like Archimedian,
it's much harder to mess up.
Simplest polyhedron that messes
up is this sliver tetrahedron.
So the polyhedron
is drawn at the top.
It's a little hard to
see, but on the backside,
there's an edge like
that, if you can imagine.
So it's almost
flat, so that's why
it's drawn flat, and
the four corners,
like a tetrahedron
should have, four faces,
the front two triangles
and the back two
triangles with the
line that I drew.
And if you unfold it in a simple
way, you just cut from a to b,
it unfolds like
this, no problem.
But if you unfold
the wrong way, which
is to cut both of
the diagonal lines,
then you end up with the
spears that cross each other,
so you really have
to be careful.
In fact, if you take
a random polyhedron--
I choose 80 points on a
sphere, I take the convex hull.
It's a very nice, round
sphere-like polyhedron.
And I look at all
the unfoldings--
this is probably not
all the unfoldings,
but I randomly generate
unfoldings, and I evaluate,
what is the observed
probability that I get overlap?
And it's very close to 100%.
The conjecture is that
as n goes to infinity,
the probability of
overlap goes to 1.
We don't have a proof of that.
That would be nice to prove.
There's good reason to
believe that's easy to prove
or that it's true, let's
say, that there is a proof.
I don't know how to
actually formalize it.
This is some work
from the late '80s.
Just because most
unfoldings fail
doesn't mean there isn't
one unfolding that works.
If I were to try to prove that
there is an unfolding that
works, here's my best hope,
and it ties into some things
that we've seen
with tensegrities.
If you take a really big
polyhedron, which is the case
you worry about, and you look
at a small portion of it,
that portion will be
almost completely flat.
Locally, this thing
is mostly flat.
Instead of thinking
about the big polyhedron,
if we at least wanted to
get it to work in any patch,
think about the case of
an almost flat polyhedron.
So it's like a little dome.
It has boundary now.
Makes life a little
harder, but let's say
it's a nice, convex boundary.
This is a convex dome.
It's actually polyhedral.
Well, let's make it
super, super flat.
So we have this z-coordinate.
Scale z to squash it
down into the plane.
What's nice about
this is then you
can think of your
convex polyhedron
just as some drawing
in the plane.
So here maybe is my
convex polyhedron.
Now, in fact, each
of these vertices
is lifted a tiny amount,
some infinitesimal amount,
but you can think
of it in the plane.
These are convex faces.
We know this thing can be
lifted to a convex polyhedron.
That lifting is
a positive stress
on all the edges except
the boundary edges.
Maybe that stress gives
you some useful structure.
If there's any hope
of this working,
that structure better be useful,
but I don't know how to use it.
But in particular,
open question.
If I give you a super
shallow, arbitrarily
shallow, convex polyhedral
dome, can it be unfolded?
I don't know.
Maybe we'll work on it
in the problem session.
Haven't thought
about it for awhile.
That's if you want
to solve everything.
What if you just want to
solve some special cases?
That is a special case
motivated by the general case.
Well, you can solve the
case of a polyhedron
with at most six vertices.
That's as far as we've gotten.
You can solve some simple
examples like pyramids
if you take any convex
polygon, doesn't
have to be irregular
or anything,
and then you take a point
and you take the convex hull.
So that's a polyhedron
and it unfolds.
How does it unfold?
Any suggestions where to cut?
How?
AUDIENCE: From the top?
PROFESSOR: From the top.
Yeah, just cut here.
Here, we're only allowed
to cut along edges.
This is called the
volcano unfolding.
What do we have?
Like that, and then there's
just a bunch of triangles.
What's nice about
the volcano unfolding
is if you look at these
perpendicular strips here,
those triangles will fit inside
those perpendicular strips,
and therefore they won't
intersect each other
because these strips don't
intersect each other.
You could probably
even continuously bloom
this, no problem.
So a very simple example,
easy to do with volcanoes.
That's the so-called pyramid.
Prism, a little bit more
interesting, but not by much.
You take some polygon.
Again, doesn't
have to be regular,
but you take two copies of
it vertically offset, take
the convex hull.
This one you can
cut in two ways.
You could do a
volcano-like thing
where you cut all
the vertical edges
and then you cut all but
one of the bottom edges.
Then you'll have basically a
volcano with little rectangles
hanging off all the sides.
And then there's another copy,
the bottom copy of this face,
and it just hangs out
over here, and you
could prove that that
won't hit anybody
in this very simple situation.
There's another unfolding,
though, that I mention
because it's useful
for other things,
and it's so-called
band unfolding.
Band unfolding, I
want to keep intact
the radial band around the
thing, maybe like this.
What do I want to do
to keep that edge?
Cut, cut.
So I cut on all the
top edges except one,
I cut on all the bottom
edges except the same one,
and then I also cut
this vertical edge.
So what I should get
is I get my top face,
then I get a
rectangle, then I get
the band that goes
around the outside,
and then I get another copy
of my shape, the bottom side.
This is what we
call band unfolding.
There's some nice theorems about
band unfoldings working out.
Let me get to more
interesting polyhedra.
These are some
pretty simple cases,
but we don't know very
much on the positive side.
Prismoid.
Suppose you take a polygon,
and you basically inset it.
So I want to make a new
version of the polygon
where all of the angles match,
so these edges are parallel
to each other.
I think, actually, the
lengths can change.
And then you take
the convex hull.
These unfold with the
volcano unfolding.
It's a little more
subtle to prove
but it's proved in the textbook.
Edges have to stay parallel.
I think that might
force something.
I'm not quite sure,
but the constraints
are that the edges
have to be parallel
and the angles have to be equal.
Dome.
Dome is actually in
some ways simpler.
You take some base, and then
I want a whole bunch of faces
that all touch the base.
So in general, it's going to be
like a tree of faces, something
like this.
Every face has to touch
an edge of the base.
These also unfold, and
also with a volcano.
This is proved also
in the textbook.
Both results are
by Joe O'Rourke.
Prismatoid.
This is the coolest
special case I'm
going to talk about,
the most interesting.
I take some convex polygon,
and then in a parallel offset,
I take some other
convex polygon--
no relation to each
other except that they're
in parallel planes--
and then I take
the convex hull,
something like that.
This one, sadly, is open.
Now, what we do know,
and this is related
to the band
unfolding, if you look
at the band around the
sides of this prismatoid
and just unfold
that by itself, that
will not self intersect,
and that's quite nontrivial,
the proof.
But if you just
unroll the side faces,
they will wander around but
they won't hit themselves.
The only remaining
problem is, where
does the top and
the bottom face go?
I think I have an example
where that's a little dicey.
Prism.
Prismoid.
That gives you an
answer to your offset.
So they can be sheared
away from each other,
but this is a prismoid.
All of the sides are parallel
and the angles match, a and b.
Here is the volcano
unfolding of the prismoid,
and here's showing that it's
not so obvious that it always
works.
If you're not careful where
you put the top face-- so this
is a on top of b
in plan-- you could
attach a to any of these faces.
You have to choose
one that's not
so inside because
it's overlapping here.
But if you choose
the outermost one,
it works and you can prove that.
This is the dome.
You can even have
overhang and they
will unfold, volcano style.
You no longer have those
nice perpendicular wedges
to say everything is disjoined.
But it still turns out.
Nothing intersects.
Here's the prismatoid
I wanted to show you.
This one's actually almost flat.
So a is this triangle right on
top of b, the triangle beneath.
You take the convex
hull and you get
all those edges on the outside.
And if you're not careful--
this is more volcano
style unfolding-- but
you can get overlap.
One thing we do know,
this is kind of weird.
If you try to go more general,
and instead of taking a convex
polygon on the top and a
convex polygon on the bottom,
instead you take a
smooth convex curve
on the top and a
on the bottom, which is getting
weird because now there's
infinitely many
vertices and going
to be infinitely many cuts.
But there is a natural
notion of unfolding
which sort of takes
the continuum.
You take all those lines
that go from one side
to the other, the rule
lines of the convex shape,
and you just unfold them.
You don't actually preserve
area when you do this.
It's not a valid unfolding
in the usual sense,
but it's a natural
generalization
of unfolding to smooth shapes.
You can prove, well, that part's
going to work just fine if you
just volcano it, and
then you can actually
find a place for the top face.
Those are the special
cases we know,
and even some pretty simple
cases that we don't know,
although it's almost there.
One more open problem.
Just mention this because
it's a fun problem.
So again, I want to edge
unfold all convex polyhedra,
but I allow multiple
pieces to make
the problem a little easier.
So let's say I have a
polyhedron with f faces.
I want to know how few
pieces could I get away with?
The big open problem is, can
I get away with one piece?
What if you make it easier?
What if I just want, say,
little o of f pieces?
Smaller than any
constant times f.
This is open.
What we do know is
some constant times
f where the constant
is less than 1.
Best constant I have
written here is 1/2.
There is a better
bound, but I think
it's not so easy to
summarize in this form.
So you can get a
little less than half
the faces' number of pieces,
but that's pretty pathetic.
It's a problem that seemed
like it would be a good idea,
but so far it hasn't seemed to
make the problem much easier.
What do I mean by pieces?
Well, we're all about
one piece unfolding,
so now your cutting
can have cycles in it
and disconnect the surface
into multiple parts.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Multiple
connected components.
The tricky part is
to pair up the faces
so that everybody has a mate.
That's not always possible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You would hope that one
third, but-- I mean,
you can do lots of
little local arguments
and prove this constant,
but the big question
is, can you get less
than a constant?
So last topic for today is edge
unfolding non-convex polyhedra.
Sort of did that
problem addressed,
and now this is not
always possible.
So I want to give you a
polyhedron where you cannot
edge unfold it.
This is actually pretty easy,
and we did it way back in '98
when we started
working on folding,
but it's kind of cheating.
This is a box on a box,
and the only edges here
are the edges of the two boxes.
There's no edges connecting
the outside of this face
to the inside of that face.
That face here is a donut.
It's a square donut.
So if you're only cutting along
edges, that face is intact.
Now I ask you, where
does the top box go?
The top box has five
square faces, not six.
There's nothing on the bottom.
And somehow, it has to
be attached to the rest
if I want one piece.
That means that all
five faces fit in here,
but there's only room
for one in terms of area
so you're screwed.
But this is cheating because
what I really wanted to do
was generalize this
problem, edge unfolding
of convex polyhedra.
Now, I know they're not
going to look convex,
but that thing is
really not convex.
It's really not
convex in the sense
that you have this face that is
not even topologically a disk.
It has a hole in it.
Convex polyhedra
don't have that.
So in some sense, this
is a topological problem,
you might say.
And you might hope that if
I looked at polyhedra that
are topologically
convex, maybe those
would unfold by edge cuts.
"Topologically convex"
means that if you just
move the vertices around but
preserve the edge structure,
then it becomes a
convex polyhedron.
In other words, I take a
convex polyhedron, which
we think maybe has
an edge unfolding,
and then I just pull
the vertices around
but preserve all the faces.
Then can you edge unfold those?
And the answer is no.
I have one more example
before we get there.
This polyhedron, at least
all the faces are disks.
There's no holes.
So it's a cube with
little bites taken out
of all the edges, same paper.
And this thing also
does not unfold.
It's a little less obvious.
What's cheating about
this example is you
have two faces, like this
purple one and the yellow one,
that share two different edges.
And for convex polyhedra,
two faces either
share an edge or a
vertex or nothing,
but they can't reach
around and do to joins.
Again, this is not topologically
convex, but this is.
So this is two views
of the same thing,
and if I take these spikes and
I just push that vertex down
to be really close to this
triangle, this will be convex.
So it's just a convex
polyhedron that I
pull on four of the points.
Same facial structure.
This has no edge unfolding
and we're going to prove that.
This example is even
stronger in that
all the faces are triangles.
So what we're going to
do is take this thing.
It's kind of appropriate
for this season.
So I've got a
tetrahedral spike on top.
Think of that as going
out of the board.
And then in the plane of
the board is this triangle,
and then I just add
in all the edges
to make it a triangulation.
Adding edges is a
worry because that's
where we're allowed
to cut, so you really
have to worry about
all those edges we add.
If we add them in
that way, I claim,
you take this-- we call
it the witch's hat--
then you multiply, in some
sense, by a tetrahedron,
meaning I take four
copies of this hat,
I put one on each face
of the tetrahedron,
and you get that example.
Here's one witch's hat and
they're just joined along edges
to make the tetrahedron.
You could do this
with bigger polyhedra,
too, like octahedron, anything
with equilateral triangles,
but tetrahedron is the
smallest where it works.
Just two of them glued face
to face would not work,
but this way does work.
Is that true?
Now I've got to think about two
of them joined face to face.
I don't think it works.
Otherwise, we would
have done that.
Oh yes, I think I see why.
Why doesn't this work?
I should say it doesn't work
if the spikes are really tall
and the base is really flat.
I'm going to define
what "really" means,
but we'll get there.
So here's our witch's hat.
When this spike is really
tall, these angles, alpha,
are very close to 90,
a little bit under 90.
This angle in the floor here--
well, this angle in the floor
is about 60, probably
actually is exactly 60.
This is an equilateral triangle.
So if this thing is very flat,
this angle will be almost 300
because it's 360 minus 60.
It'll be a little bit less
than 300 but almost 300.
These matter.
In particular, the
total sum of angles
here is 300 plus twice
90, which is big.
It's bigger than 360.
That's the point.
In fact, 300 plus one
of these angles, 90,
would be almost 390,
which is way above 360.
So this has negative curvature,
and even if you cut out
one of the spike
triangles, it would still
have negative curvature.
That's going to be bad
news because let's just
imagine for the moment.
We know unfolding
things with boundary
is hard, but let's pretend
for now that you wanted
to unfold a hat in isolation.
You wanted to unfold it into
one piece without overlap.
Think about what you could do.
I have to cut with
a spanning forest,
I guess, meaning
it's acyclic, it's
got to hit all the vertices.
There's only four vertices here.
How could I hit all the
vertices with a forest?
You may recall from way back
when that trees have leaves.
Every tree has at
least two leaves.
Here I might have multiple
trees, maybe, but unlikely,
and I have to have
at least to leaves.
Where could those two leaves be?
Could they be at any leaves
or vertices at degree one?
Could they be at any of
these three vertices?
No, because they have
negative curvature.
We know a vertex with
negative curvature
has to have at least
two cuts incident to it.
You can't stop at
these three vertices.
That only leaves one
vertex and the boundary.
So the only thing
you can do if you
want to visit all the
vertices and start somewhere
on the boundary and get
to the x, get to the peak.
That's all you can do.
You couldn't have multiple
connections to the boundary
because then you
would disconnect.
Then there's really
only two choices
and they're
reflectionally symmetric.
And we're only allowed
to go along edges.
It's super constrained.
You can go here, walk
around, and go up,
or you can walk around
the other way and go up.
Those are actually slightly
different because you
have two choices of which
edge to follow here.
They're both screwed
because if you
look at this point, the
white dot, or the white dot
up there, what remains
here on the outside
is almost 300 degrees
of material on the base
plus one of the 90 degree
faces, the back one
that you can't see.
It's easier to see here.
You have the 300
degrees on the bottom
and then the white face
is still attached to it,
and that's almost 390.
When you flatten
that thing, it's
going to overlap
itself at that point.
Bad news.
So this just says, if I
look at a hat in isolation,
it can't unfold, but that's
not what I care about.
I care about four of
them joined together.
Suppose you had some
unfolding of the whole thing,
and then I look
at, well, what cuts
happen within the witch's hat?
I know the witch's hat
cannot remain in one piece.
Therefore, it must
be disconnected
into multiple pieces,
something like this.
Again, the cuts have to visit
all the vertices somehow,
but we know from the
perspective of a single hat,
that hat must split
into two parts.
There are lots of things
you could consider.
Let's suppose this is
possible, not even worry
about these kinds of pictures.
Well, I claim we have a problem.
Here's a tetrahedron.
These vertices are all
the same point, actually.
I've just unfolded
the tetrahedron
because it's way easier
to draw in two dimensions.
So if I look at the hat
that is on this triangle,
this hat gets disconnected
into two parts.
There's only three
connection points
to the rest of the world.
So what these pictures
have to look like is they
connect two of the vertices
by a collection of cuts.
If you're going to
cut into two halves,
you've got to have
a path across,
and there's only three
vertices to visit.
There's some collection
of cuts that go from,
let's say, this
vertex to this vertex.
At this point,
everything's symmetric.
Maybe it would be more obvious
if I started the center.
It could be from
here to there, could
be from here to there or from
here to there, but at least one
of those things exist,
and by rotational symmetry
of this diagram,
say it's that one.
Well, what happens to this face?
Could there be
something like this?
No, because then this
would be disconnected
from the rest of the world.
So suddenly, this
hat is constrained.
Maybe it could look like this.
You have a choice.
It could look like
that or like that,
but by reflectional
symmetry, same thing.
So let's say this one.
Remember, x is the
same everywhere.
Well, that means
this is impossible
because this edge is
actually glued to this edge,
and so then this thing
would be disconnected
from the rest of the world.
So there's a couple
of possibilities.
It could look like this,
or it could look like this.
It was one of those
two for this face.
We've got one face left.
This is impossible because
this edge glues to this one,
so imagine this thing being
picked up and moved over here.
So we have a wiggly line
here and then this stuff,
and so that would
be disconnected
from the rest of the world,
so that can't happen.
What about this one?
Is that the harder one?
I don't know.
It's been a while since
I've used the argument.
If we have this
together with this,
that's clearly bad because
that forms a cycle.
No good.
But what if I have this
together with this one?
It gets hard to see.
It's bad.
It's a cycle.
It starts and ends at x,
and if you fold it up right,
you'll see there's really
two sides to that cycle.
It's actually forced,
so that's bad.
All right, one more
choice, this one.
If I do this together
with this one,
that's going to be bad
because that's a cycle.
We start and end at x.
What if I do this
one and that one?
Well, that's also
bad because here's
a cycle that starts
at x, ends at x.
This and this form the
inner of the cycle.
All cases are bad,
so no edge unfolding.
Tragic.
We can think briefly about
the case-- do I have time?
I have 10 seconds.
About the case where
there are two triangles.
I guess I should
draw them like this.
So this point is the
same as this point.
So if I try to simplify this,
instead of using four hats,
I just use two hats,
put one here, one here.
Then I could do something
like this, I think,
and maybe that's OK if
there's no cycle formed there.
So we really needed the
tetrahedron somehow.
I think it does work for
octahedron and larger also,
but just two triangles
is not enough.
And that is unfolding.
We did not always edge foldable
for general polyhedra, even
topologically convex polyhedra.
Next time, we'll talk more
about general unfolding
of arbitrary polyhedra.